hello and welcome to the lobby
gamespot's weekly chat show here on
gamespot com maybe tuesday 2 p.m.
pacific or if you're watching this on
demand on gamespot com or the youtubes
my name is Daniel Dwyer I'm delighted to
be joining my mr. Christopher waters
Danny what's up buddy hey no my friend
ah good doing real good start and get
prep for pack south which is next week
yes I forgot that is the thing that's
happening and mr. Peter Brandon's here
back and see yes happy new year how are
you doing I'm good what's a nice like to
be back from the world of bed room
essentials and washing machines but LED
LED screens amazing my lips are not
shaft anymore from the dry desert air
and I'm not forced to placate PR reps
pulling me aside to look at their new
fangled rubber that prevents phones from
Canada well we're good do as much as I
like talking about a newfangled rubber
we're and talk about video games and a
little bit worried about like talking
about games on the show this month
because there's not too much coming out
but thankfully there is a remake of a
resident evil remake coming out resident
evil HD remastered which is the i guess
the remastered version of the resident
is a remastered version of resident evil
HD or is it that GameCube version that's
now being brought out on new consoles
it's a HD remaster of the gamecube
version yes is not HD know the price
right so so very confusing a little bit
confusing and it's the it's the latest
in a long long line of Resident Evil
games some of very a very high quality
it could be said and some of rather
dubious quality we're gonna talk about I
guess this sort of our best and least
favorite in the core like six but
there's probably been about 20 but we're
not gonna let wait like on games because
they're all unanimously [ __ ] oh come
on that's not true you don't like to
have a good time would like on gay I
don't know resident evil I'm let's talk
let's start from the start let's do
chronologically Resident Evil One what
are your thoughts Peter Brandt that was
the first PlayStation game i ever played
and scared the crap out of me as a kid
I've gone back recently to play it only
to sort of like get myself context for
the new version is coming out so is it
pretty well but
I mean can I talk about the gamecube
reman go for it yeah like that to me is
the best Resident Evil game that's
available currently what makes it better
than the 1999 like original PlayStation
1 sorry 1986 my dad my bad i mean this
game usable though their game keep
remake uses lighting to such a great
effect and you know like did at least
we're talking about right now you know
like going back and playing the old one
yes it sort of has a nostalgic appeal
but this game even on the gamecube still
holds up but like what you're seeing
right here I think this footage is from
the gamecube or physics like armor by
three but it's even by today's standards
it's a beautiful-looking game and if we
want to talk about compared to the
series at whole i mean i think yes this
is where everything started and there
have been some advancements that made
the series little bit better in some
ways but this game is still the one for
me that encapsulates what it is to be a
survival horror game some of that's
broken with the items stuff but you
really have to manage all your items
it's really hard unless you know the
game like the back your hand to know
what's coming and it's just the
atmosphere is so great and that mansion
that game is fascinating to me as like a
modern case study for survival horror
because when you play that game in 1996
or years ago whatever it's not you it it
wasn't uh it was like you can do these
new things like like moving around in a
3d space like going but from camera
angle the camera angle that was still
like pretty much the standard yeah for
how stuff would go but now if you play
it all of those things that were sort of
on the cutting edge of things you can do
in video games are now restrictions and
so you're actively like working back
into this previous era and restricting
your abilities and like you design a
game with restrict now restricting what
you can do that's that's part of the
game design this game wasn't designed
yes necessarily that way you know so
it's different it was more of a meat
needs most kind of you know we can do
this now is not like oh god I have to
I'm a tank control I can I'm gonna try
to take a headshot oh you're too close
visited maybe I'll just oh ok this is
mate our that'll work out that's weird I
guess without the would have nostalgia
like it probably comes off as super off
it was also on the sort of bleeding edge
of like taste because I remember when
the director's cut came out
think it was a year later like I had
stuff that bit where the zombie bites
the guy's head off in a Rolls like they
haven't shown that before because they
were like awww people can't see a
severed head in a video game right and
then by the time resident evil 2 K mesh
which was 1998 and that game was kind of
like the like Tomb Raider 22 tomb raider
like I always felt like it was way less
scary more of just like an action romp
it's still I mean maybe you could say
there was a bit more action it was
definitely a way more intense experience
because unlike the original house for
you it was just kind of like you and
like old crusty wallpaper may be a
zombie hear their crusty wallpaper that
house was in very good condition sure
the ribbon able to I mean you know
you're in the cityscape environment
they're like things on fire you know
you're dealing with all these just sort
of like you know lots of variety of
things happening which you know it's
that game still struck a chord a lot of
people I liked it quite a bit but it
just it wasn't it didn't feel as special
to me as the first game and that might
be a nostalgia talking even then you
know for this year's the past I haven't
seen this video in like 10 years I
remember this blew my mind and I first
thought yeah these games are really on
the sort of bleeding edge of i'm not
sure if it was a graphic so just style i
remember thinking like these games
didn't they look like nothing else we'd
ever seen i think it's kind of the
cinematography as well of these yeah it
seems like it demonstrates you not like
the framing of it like it's it's not
just like show them some cool stuff we
can you know that has the most cool
animations on it that we can cram in
there it's like create this dramatic
tension with these camera angles which
of course this series has always done
really well and that a year later
resident evil 3 nemesis came out which I
always remember having sort of being
more mechanically interesting rather
than anything else because you had that
like recurring boss fight with nemesis
he come back and like you were like
taking chunks off him and then like
trying to like not trying to kill him
we're just trying to survive and like
run away from them constantly and but I
don't I didn't really play too much of
us do you have fond memories of Nemesis
I remember I enjoyed playing the game I
never actually got to the chance of
finishing it but yeah I get like you
know it's sort of in a city like you're
constantly fleeing as you described
which is definitely something that's
different because
is fast yeah Emma says he was fast and
strong hit a rocket launcher mean for an
arm yeah like you could not be in that
way well he yeah but yeah I mean you had
said you had to constantly just like be
on your toes and that was interesting
that was a good addition but i think
this series like as it whenever tries to
add certain things it begins to kind of
like chip away at what made the original
game so special and it's fair to say
that the next game after a six-year
hiatus Resident Evil 4 was quite a leap
in terms of gameplay in terms of what
the original three were and almost
indistinguishable you could have said
that it wasn't the Resident Evil game at
all and that's probably my favorite of
the the core series i think for was
tremendous it was one of the game is
when i got a gamecube there were like
five or six games that came out in that
system that were aptly must plays and
ready for was the game that was the
system seller for me basically and like
even today this game i think holds up
incredibly well but with the cover
shooting there like over the show
shoulders third person stuff just creepy
his head like that that first resin he
was really good at like those iconic
moments like you always remember like
opening the door and the mansion for the
first time and the time the like the dog
jumps through the window that we see
that spider like the first seen in this
when you're in that town and you're like
using the ladders and like just trying
to survive yeah you don't kill
everything like your mode is your like
goal is basically to just try and
survive this horde of crazy sort of
spanish mountain people like I still
don't know some of the hell is going on
there and do you find memories of four
as well a little bit I kind of as a
series went on I trail off a little bit
the but the over-the-shoulder thing it's
not that was big not just for resident
evil but also for video games I mean
that mmm this game kind of set made that
a standard in a lot of ways and we saw
it you know iterated upon and like games
like Gears of War you know where it's
used to great effect as well and there
were other third person action games but
that's kind of where people decided like
I want this view more like yummy this
and we got more of us in Resident Evil 5
it's fair to say after four I don't know
stakes were high or people that core
series was just even though they've been
a lot of [ __ ] happening in the
resident evil world out
that I have another good ones I code
veronica was it was a pretty great game
and that core series was still like
pretty good quality wise and I think
five perhaps because of the high bar
that that series has felt pretty sure
well I mean you can't like following for
I mean the way that's one of those games
just comes at the right time and it's
just so phenomenal and so influential
that like when it knocks on to you know
the next generation of consoles and into
sort of what do we want from an HD like
we're basically resonable for again and
this is like you get resin evil for but
like pumped up a bit more and you've got
two characters and like you're all you
sort of have this call of duty
globe-trotting thing going on if I coop
coop I had a blast playing this game you
know as ridiculous as some of the scenes
whereas utterly stupid is like jamming a
button to punch a boulder well like ever
ever live in my memory they're still
like there's still those scenes like in
that town where that executioner's
coming after you where you're
frantically running around through these
narrow spaces and like discovering which
windows you can jump through and
definitely want you playing that not
co-op was kind of vexing because uh vai
not quite as collection chef achieva
chef chef ever yeah I know Mary put
together a list of the sort of best
co-op games of the past couple years I'm
like that was one that she mentioned
playing and enjoying quite a lot
actually kind of bummed out that I did
not play Rosie fight with somebody else
because of that those problems and I
think by the time six came along in a
twenty20 he just feel the toes curling
already in 2012.the the bar was kind of
brought down a bit like the expectations
and that game still managed to fall way
short of them yeah yeah and I think that
was just like okay we've basically got
the four we extrapolated into five but
uh people you know that it didn't quite
make the splash that afforded so pretty
solid let's let's just amp it up a notch
instead of two characters we're gonna
bring in all these other characters
we're gonna have all these other crazy
scenes and there's t-virus gonna go
bonkers or whatever it's called it
whatever iteration is at this point this
just seemed like let's make this
more of a roller coaster ride and less
of this kind of tension this kind of a
straightforward action game and it was
just I actually barely even played it
because i watched kevin review it about
and it was dire i remember the fall out
when Kevin league was 4.5 at got in the
end and people were pretty pissed off
about that as they tend to be in reviews
when when it's a bit of a shock score
but within days of people actually
seeing this in playing this for
themselves it was it was pretty clear
that this was not a good video game by
any standard it's almost like they tried
to make a call of duty Resident Evil
game okay just the amount of like action
set pieces like a bizarre leaning on
quick time events that had never existed
before in series so many QuickTime
events there was some in for I fest
where I kind of started with this series
yeah but man just I mean even if it's
not a resident evil game you're talking
about when you're talking about this
like it's just still not great it's all
over the place is it fair to say that
that is the worst resident evil or do
you think there's maybe one outside of
the core franchise that is slightly
worse yeah the operation Raccoon City oh
yes people hate that game that was the
four player co-op that can make this a
year I came out the same year yeah yeah
Jane Douglas reviewed that person again
yeah but you're like these cookie cutter
like warrior or you know I don't even
know the story I get why is this a
resident evil king is an operation it's
in Raccoon City and you have to shoot
people and it's class-based and their
parents looked pretty bad I mean amateur
like when I first heard about this I was
interested it's like oh this is clearly
departure from the main line series like
it's in that world sure it's a creepy
place there's weird stuff going on you
could you can make something happen but
yeah the way this one just came together
did not not super great although I I
feel like six was worse yeah thats
that's how i came away with my
impression of operation Raccoon City all
right let's bring it in to a vote then
let's individualize it Peter favorite
and least favorite Resident Evil game
favorites got to be the remake of the
original ok be at the gamecube one or
the current-gen that's coming out least
favorite uh probably six I can with
confidence agent
played I played a couple hours of that
and really just hated that I'd spent a
couple hours per second at Chris uh well
for is my top okay solutely that was a
game like it takes a lot for Resident
Evil game to pull me in so so
traumatized and the first one it took me
like years to fit you don't like scary
yes sir was like get that they're
deliberately just like horror your world
is terrible like I'm not down with that
so it's kind of a stretch for me to even
want to play a Resident Evil game and
for utterly absorb me I loved it so much
but if there was like if it was even
like not that quality there's no
question to me even playing it so I
didn't play six I didn't I haven't
played a bunch of them yeah so you know
for worse I don't have no vote okay fair
enough limit I'm gonna throw in Jordan
cystic I am played six either and you
know I don't like making qualitative
assessments on stuffed i haven't played
but he looks like a real piece of our
trash yeah yeah resident evil 6 for me
and i probably say for as well but let's
let's tie it let's say one and for the
remake for the best and six taking home
the the dishonorable discharge bearing
on my friend fair those are our winners
and losers for the best and worst
Resident Evil game a few many thoughts
yourself by all means put them in the
comments and I let us know what you
think yourself alright we're going back
in a second to talk about another
returning favorite Zelda right after we
check out and the latest trailer for
evolved there's another trainer for
evolved there's somebody trailers for
evolved his latest 8040 vault
2014 was quite the year for the Nintendo
Wii U and it seems like 2015's got some
great games coming up for that system as
well one of which will hopefully be the
new Zelda Peter I see you rubbing your
loins was I in my mind wishful thinking
you're that you're doing that I'd get a
better zelda round no all right Peter
you're excited though yeah a new zelda
game yeah what's not to be excited dude
yeah open-world Zelda yes I mean I
didn't honestly like the last Zelda game
I play that I enjoyed was on the 3ds
right the love affair traffic between
worlds alright sorry now he's bein
sports game as a year for 2013 indeed
spirit truck but like I played Skyward
Sword and I I got I felt burned right
away really it was like two hours of
them treating link like he is the most
boneheaded subhuman to ever walk the
plan okay yes but I will stand up for
that game only because once you get past
that it's a pretty great game sure a lot
of people enjoying it sure I couldn't
get facet it's like a day hey Peter no I
remember this huge bird that you've been
like life partners with our entire
existence how could you forget about if
they're so sleepy like oh well the new
zelda em is going to I guess be more of
an open-world affair which is kind of
like Zelda has always had like an open
world like a large world to explore and
maybe in a more traditional kind of you
know old nes / talk about the first game
definitely yeah and like the hub world
and then the dungeons are like little
folks off of it obviously the term open
world now sort of means something else
in like the modern video game language
sure and so what type of stuff would you
like guys like to see Peter first of all
like I've taken from other open world
games as we see today like brought into
the Zelda universe mmm I'm just gonna
avoid the whole thing from other games
thing oh yeah yeah go ahead so I mean
Zelda was sort of created out of sugar
Miyamoto's love of nature right yeah and
that game is always kind of toyed with
you know the you know the outdoors right
open world game you know with the wii u
they're able to make this huge expansive
world things that you know in the real
world if you were to sort of deal with
an environment that large you would have
to do things like camp at night you
would probably have to forge for
materials to make stuff I mean that's
the kind of things that I would love to
see injected into Zelda I don't know
that the main formula has to change hmm
I mean you could even adopt the same
system from a link between worlds where
you rent equipment you know he's a yeah
but yeah I would love to see see link
really sort of tied in with nature and
maybe even something like a real-time
day/night cycle to encourage players to
all encourage devs to do something
interesting with that you know with
multiple instances of the same world but
with a different things happening and
you know yeah like have linked maybe
have to set up camp mmm what the Zelda
series has always had like a sort of an
interesting relationship with the
day/night cycle some games some games
have it some games didn't have it in
like towns for instance some did in the
overworld but then you look at something
like majora's mask which was a game that
was almost defined by the fact that like
nighttime was a constant threat and what
type of stuff would you like to see
Zelda universe do with like a regular
day night cycle like stuff like we see
in other games where you know maybe it's
easier to attack it like a camp at a
different time or may very well as Final
Fantasy 15 is doing something where the
enemy is at night are stronger and
different you know and like to see
something like that where they had dick
and you know things that are sort of you
know recoil in the daylight might come
out of their little caves and actually
pose a bigger threat to link but then
maybe the rewards could be better as
well but yeah like I think if you could
do that and have links sort of deal with
you know like when you turn off the game
like have link set up camp right or if
it's during the daytime have him go do
some tasks you know while the sun's
still out I don't know I just I would
just love to see some of that and maybe
if they could bring back something like
you know boating or flying all right
yeah yeah yeah I'll give link you know
he always has a relationship with you
pona and Skyward Sword he had the bird I
mean I don't see why you couldn't bring
another bird into the equation and why
link also couldn't hop on another boat
like he didn't win winner at christie
you were talking before about the sort
of
and the relationship with opponent hair
like other games have used horse riding
and like transportation to good effect
probably red dead redemption yeah I mean
I was thinking about okay so what is
what's kind of an open world what what
makes me want to stay in an open world
what's an open world that I've like just
relished being in the openness of it not
just kind of passing through and red
dead redemption as a stellar example I
think one of the reasons it harks back
to a Peter saying is about that
connection with nature having having
moments where I'm just like riding along
a hillside and like I just want to stop
and take in the view because oh my god
this is beautiful or you know like I see
some birds off in the distance or
something and just like just like have a
moment that makes me feel connected
makes me feel like exploration is a
reward in and of itself just because of
the design I do think that there are
ways to use a horse that's that could be
more creative and could sort of create
those kind of emerging opportunities you
know not young Allah Far Cry we're like
some you run by and some people were
just in a fight and maybe you come help
them out or you know in red dead you
have those two or you like a woman's out
in the desert you go help her and like
maybe you actually help her or maybe
like three dudes pop out from her busted
cart and try to shoot you like I think
emergence stuff like that could be neat
for the Zelda universe because they've
always felt you know compared to like a
red dead I feel like Zelda places have
always felt like towns or where people
are and like maybe there's that one guy
by that tree but the open world doesn't
quite feel as lived in by the residents
of the world and a lot of times like oh
because there are monsters out there
that's the way they explain it but I
think that like having it be more lived
in and having a little more character
like from the people you encounter um
well it could be really neat one of the
things that I might limited my
experience itself is relatively limited
I think especially in comparison to you
Peter one of the things i always felt
yeah right yeah you tell eliminate don't
know what but one of the things that I
always find interesting about the Zelda
games is that they are very focused on
the protagonist and the sort of thing
that we see a lot of an open world games
now is the
often the world itself is the actual
character and you're just kind of
playing a part in it I guess by
definition of like his sort of I guess
quest that it's always going to be about
him but I always feel like they feel you
know not a detriment necessarily but
they feel like worlds that have been put
out there so that Zelda or sorry so that
link can interact with them I never get
a real sense of place from a lot of
these games and what I'd like to see is
perhaps what you see in games like
Skyrim or fall out where you kind of you
run into almost inconsequential like
color stories like side quests that may
end up benefiting you in terms of like
equipment you have or like your your
character or they might just be there as
like options that give you sort of a
better understanding of the world
because the worlds in Zelda are always
so lost and interesting and beautiful
but I never feel like connected them
deep just from your experience in
playing other Zelda games do you think
that that's a fair assessment that like
those games are kind of that they don't
have that much depth to them as like
societies or places that people live in
yeah I can't really think of a game
that's really dealt like taking a deep
dive into the culture of the world of
Hyrule maybe that's because it's it's
already established in a way and we know
but it but it does change it does change
I think like a good example from the
trailer that they showed during e3 I was
linked just sort of hanging out on the
hill and you see that sort of monster in
the background and he kind of rides up
to it and they fight it's not exactly
what you're talking about but I think
it's that at least shows me that it's a
living breathing world that's out there
and when link is sort of interacting
with this you know this monster it sort
of it's not like a guy who's sort of
like placed between him and objective
yeah you know given the open-world
aspect of it you're going to expect you
sort of emergent experiences but but
hopefully that's indicative of maybe you
know a Hyrule that's in I mean I'd love
to see a Hyrule before it's all
established you know like as these
villages are being set up you know as
people are learning to live off the land
maybe or inna and then build their
society around that like that'd be
really cool but ya know like a frontier
kind of part of Hyrule like you've got
the core I probably have a castle right
but like the areas where people are like
just sort of setting out and like pigs
got wouldn't bunch wooden sticks around
their tents yeah I mean I dude I'd like
it without a castle honestly like it'd
be great to see something that is really
kind of primitive in a sense excellent
I'd be interesting yeah I think that for
me like one of one of the other things
that I think that places of the Zelda
could stand to grow is with NPCs and as
you know because you have the one so you
just there like kind of silly there to
sitting around you come up to them and
they make a little joke and then you
have the ones that you are a little more
substantial you like maybe do one quest
for them you gather the ladies chickens
or and then you have the ones that are
recurring quests where you've got a
weird octopus lady under a mountain that
you keep bringing her baby's back to I
feel like I feel like you know I want to
have some more articulation in terms of
the level of NPCs so like give me
someone who I talked to and like have a
relationship with and it deepens and
when I come back they say it's great to
see you again when I come back to third
time they say hey man how's it been
going I look I've been really have like
having a tough time and you get some
more dialogue out of them you get more
personality because link is not exactly
overflowing with personality yeah you
know he's kind of a cipher for you the
player so in order for there to be
personality in the game the world needs
to have it and the people need to have
it and then if you talk to those people
enough then eventually you get to have
sex with them like in massive egg yeah
one can help that's the future of all
video games eventually it's a weird
segue into my invention of the
gravedigger from aa cricket not somebody
you want to have sex with excitedly but
like a good example of an NPC in a zelda
world that is that has some depth you
know and you get to learn a little bit
about him and actually feel something
for him Dante excellent although I guess
we'll find out later this year join me
Peter join me Chris do it bill join me
and I hope you're all rubbing your loins
at home as well add the new zelda game
will be out on with you later this year
if you have any thoughts on what you
think should be in the game by all means
put them in the comments below or send
us what you think on the twitters and
we'll be back in a second folks going to
check out the trailer for the order and
then right after that we're going to
talk about playstation now the new
streaming service which has just been
launched today on playstation 4 we're
going to talk about some of the best
games available on that service as long
as you're willing to
pay the money but first the order 1886
how so stuff
then from me
this is for the players playstation
there the brand new streaming service
from the folks at playstation and Gaikai
is now available on the playstation 4
allowing you to play video games via the
wonder of internet video streaming it's
about 100 games available in the service
right now that's costing twenty dollars
a month or $45 per quarter and currently
only available in north america and i'm
here with Peter and Chris to talk about
some of the best games currently
available on that service first of all
what do you guys think of a price and
you many games available obviously
they're going for like Netflix of gaming
twenty bucks little bit more of my used
to paying for something like Netflix or
Amazon getting video uh so for
comparison like gamefly as a rental
service you get discs mailed to you
Allah the dish looks yes what's a disc
goes into the well it's too complicated
to get into now but that's like 16 bucks
to have one game out of time for a month
and you can up into 20 a little over 20
bucks for two discs out at a time okay
so the price there it's kind of in the
same ballpark it's a little comfortable
obviously that's a whole different
things you have to mail you'll get the
one disc and you mail it back yet you
know like this as opposed to just
streaming it so I I don't know it like I
originally was balking at the price yeah
then Peter you've had it up and running
today and I had asked you even though I
know what this service I fully know what
the service is about I was like old you
get that odd get Street Fighter
installed on PlayStation now yeah it's
like no you don't have to do that you
just like to know and like there it
isn't you're playing right I don't know
if that like actually hit home to me
until you're actually doing it has
experienced work I mean so keep in mind
we're working with a like super fast
like corporate building downtown San
Francisco in a company bandwidth
connection yeah so you know considering
that it works really well um the the
video there's a little bit of
compression artifacting going on where
you know maybe if some mid tone colors
are going across the screen you'll see a
little bit of blocks here kind of
obscuring detail colonies yeah what's a
mid-tone color k gray cool
I dig mids out don't play games with
gray in looks but it's it's also not
really that distracting those those
little bits and pieces and it's
something that you'd expect you know
like you mentioned you don't have to
download the game or even if it's a disk
based game you don't to do any sort of
installation yeah like some place you
PlayStation games required and you know
what the lag was I couldn't detect any
everything yeah as I played final
fantasy 13 Metal Slug and super street
fighter 4 okay don't that being a
relatively fast game exactly yeah and I
play a lot of street fighter 4 with a
pad and doing so felt the same as it did
on a ps3 at least to me excellent so
right off the edited gate they have a
hundred titles available for you to
stream and Peter what would you say are
some of the games that are a highlight
for you on that service some of the ones
I just mentioned actually uh final
fantasy 13 is a game I would mean to
revisit for a while I'd like that series
really dope off the deep end but I think
the first game did some things that now
I'm more willing to accept and
appreciate and and considering that it's
like a long-form RPG right yeah you know
if you only sign up for a month that's a
game that could keep you busy for a long
time while you're sampling other things
I also super street fighter 4 is another
game that you can just play endlessly
right so for the the quality of the game
in the time you're allowed to play I
really like those too but then sort of
like a personal favorite is motorstorm
apocalypse oh yeah it was a racing game
that no one's talked about in a while
but that game had incredible visual
design yes or super fast really fun to
play like that's one of those games just
sort of like disappears and people move
on yeah but like that's a great game I
love the first motorstorm and I think
that was the sequel to came at like
relatively soon after like teen months
maybe two years later I don't member the
exact timing yeah but it like you said
it's completely passed me by yeah when
you're right if I have access to it
services well that also raises a
question motorstorm because you want to
race people right one raised people
online and PlayStation now games if you
if it has online multiplayer that's
enabled like oh well that's all in there
but who's like I said I mean if you go
to kill zone three and you want to play
competitive multiplayer which is great
how many people are gonna get that orb
against you know so good point that's
kind of for me when I was thinking about
like what games i would recommend i was
even though i've really enjoyed the
online multi-player a lot of those games
yeah I can't really recommend renting
them for that reason so you prefer the
single-player experience is available I
think the single-player thing is much
better and I think like I was parking
back to my like rental heyday I had
gamefly for a while but like my real
rental heyday was sega genesis going to
the store in my town before you know
when it was the local store then it was
blockbuster I don't have a second
channel I don't know what that is what
is a the PlayStation now for the Genesis
really I kid you not what you got it
through your cable provider Oh in your
system and you can just stream games Oh
cryptic the knowing was a lag like on
that oh it was not fed no I think it
saved it to local memory so it actually
don't you can hate locally well anyway
Wow Sega channel and so what games that
are I got to get out of my seat just sit
yeah when you're not using Sega China
what game is on PlayStation so I think
one of the standouts for me personally
is enslaved odyssey to the west yes
because that's it's a third person
action game you it's it's two characters
a trip and monkey you play as monkey
uses kind of brawler trip andy serkis
yeah he's like this big dude trip is the
sort of brains the operation you sort of
say you save each other from basically
being enslaved and then try to journey
across post-apocalyptic society to get
back to where you're from this is the
kind of game that maybe is a hard sell
for a buy for you because it's like oh
you're gonna dump it in seven to 10
hours i'm not exactly sure how long it
was but for rent that's a great one like
that's a weekend that's a or a week with
playing a few nights and it's got so
much personality and like the the
environmental design is really slick and
the combat is very cool as well that one
yeah absolutely enslaved and then what
was another one that's it when I wasn't
going I remember seeing on your list
which made me laugh quite a lot was a
game that's based on any list you can
ever create oh yeah spelunky I so lucky
of course the game of the year for all
years the game just fantastic
and you should own it obviously and on
everything on yeah on whatever game
system you can play it on I didn't
really shoot a spider on VW no other
Vita violent place anyways this is like
a chris is always talking about the
flunky why don't you shut up about
spelunky I don't want to buy it it
doesn't look that great rent it play
love it forever buy it be the net by an
hour every platform I can possibly
imagine and hence there was a third one
with the Trib it was bit trip Thank You
Danny I found this listing because I
haven't played one or two so this
technically it's [ __ ] represents run or
two future legend of rhythm alien yes I
think it is all right I truncated it
when we put it into the the running
order pitcher to right bit richer runner
to the [ __ ] rip series was super cool
that's a topic for another day but run
or two is you know you're constantly
running and all you're doing is pressing
buttons to slide jump kick and you know
spring in order to get past obstacles
but it's in tune with the music and like
once and like the designs of the level
are trippy it gets exponentially hard it
gets much harder and once you know if
you feels too easy you can rank up the
difficulty really simply there's a bunch
of different characters including a
reverse Merman who's like the head of
the fish and the legs of a dude who has
these huge dangling testicles which are
hilarious but really it's it dis just
nails that euphoric feeling that rhythm
games can have when you when you like
your butt your button presses the music
the level design are all in harmony it's
an incredible feeling and this game
captures it better than most awesome
it'sit's thing we talk about this
because we're bringing up games that we
have basically all played like if I was
to take about one of my favorite games
in the system it would be bioshock
infinite which is available which
probably one of the bigger like Triple A
games on it which is one of my favorite
games of 2013 yeah one of the best games
I've ever played but we're talking in
terms of these are games we have played
these are on our checklist of games that
we hope others you people should like
yes you think that's who's getting this
service or do you think like surely this
is for people who have never played
these games and want to like experience
new games like who do you think
ultimately PlayStation now is for
yeah it's a difficult question because I
think a lot of people don't really want
to go backwards they want to go forwards
when it comes to games so I don't but
but you know looking at the the list of
stuff like seeing all that these games
I've played like yeah I kind of feel
like oh I can play it up again on my
playstation 4 like I always could have
played those games again but having it
right there having an accessible and
literally it's like hit play 20 seconds
later the games they're like okay I'll
play you know I mean it makes it really
easy to revisit the past I have a
feeling that that's who's this for
because I don't know who's going to pay
money to have access to a butt load of
old game is especially ones that olds
like obviously they're going to expand
this with playstation 2 and PlayStation
1 games and do you think that's going to
sort of be more interesting in terms of
like a nostalgic trip and going back you
know five six years I'm sure the nacelle
de did nacelle just going to get
exponentially powerful when you go back
to ps2 and ps1 of course but it's
interesting yet to think about a library
of ps3 games who does that appeal to
does it appeal to someone who had two
played a lot of ps3 games and wants to
go back and play them I don't think so
because I feel like that person is on to
the ps4 does it appeal to someone who is
now getting a ps3 the guy a friend loves
to play games but doesn't want to get a
next-gen console he's had an xbox 360
for a couple years now he's going to get
a playstation 3 and play all those
exclusives all that stuff he didn't get
to play and he's super psyched about it
if he could you know when it comes to
playstation 3 pay twenty bucks sample a
bunch of those or you know play through
to completion some of them or maybe like
this is a way i was thinking maybe it's
useful as run through and sample which
ones do i want to play more of which
ones do i just want to get a taste of
you know and then kind of be done with
because just getting a taste of stuff is
kind of the core of the rental
experience yes right she's giving it a
go and seeing you like I'm not being
scared of having to throw down 60 and
then actually you know be stuck with a
game rather right and then feel like all
I have to I have to get my money's worth
of this or I have to take the hit to
resell it or something like that so I
think that could be interesting of
course the like you know am I going to
pay 20 bucks a month so I can like try
out the last of us or am I gonna try to
get the last of us you know I like I to
HD is it better to have it's better for
that reason to have
fresher more recent games but for the
nostalgia reason you got to go to the
back catalog and then they're these
games that are in the weird in-between
it's really strange it's it's a new
frontier for games obviously something
that's happening a lot and fill them in
music over the past five six years so
it's gonna be very interesting as so if
you've any thoughts on what games you
would like to see brought to the
PlayStation air service or games that
are currently on there do you think we
did not mention by all means stick them
in the comments and that's pretty much
the show for the week but I got one more
thing that I want to talk about though
joke one more thing one more thing so
there's this thing that keeps happening
with rockstar games unfortunately it
happened again today at rockstar have
announced the scranton auto 5 on pc when
they'll be coming out in late March
obviously we supposed to come out in
just under two weeks time and this is
sort of underscores a worrying trend
with rockstar games because we're
thinking around the office like this
people were anticipating that this might
happen forever because this always seems
to happen raksha game so I went back and
started like checking out just some of
the old delays that have happened over
the past couple years into jigging I
didn't digging I did some researching
sleuthing and you may remember that red
dead redemption was actually supposed to
come out in April of 2010 I'm ended up
being pushed a month to me 18 not that
bad right a month same fiscal quarter
yes like like that's what takes you care
of it it's so sure like what were they
dodging another release were they like
they just had to get that one more patch
in like a mala she's like what can you
even do in a month especially that I
mean now you can do a lot but back then
it didn't seem like he could really oh
oh don't worry there have been longer
delays at GTA 4 for instance was
originally supposed to come out in
October 2007 and ended up coming at in
April 2008 Wow so that was almost a full
as six months again within the second
fiscal quarter in fact just a day inside
at the second fiscal quarter which
obviously makes a big deal for take two
and all of their is that their cronies
is it really the second or is it the
first of their fiscal year because some
companies oh yeah january through march
is their q4
and then the new year starts q1 so I
don't know if like a rock star does that
way but I just wanted to it's not a
wrench in the works this is it this is
my fault for not having a clear about
finances really grand theft auto san
andreas was pushed back from to october
twenty sixth instead of the original
last october nineteenth and got pushed
back in Europe an extra week to october
twenty nine so again just a week it's
even shorter lived it but it seems like
a can't they can't go one game without
delay they're just gonna 7x what if we
do it will fix that thing will take out
hot coffee or put it in put it in there
slip it in yeah it's so to speak of
course that game ended up putting pulled
off shelves anyway because of hot coffee
and then put back out again and here's
an interesting one GTA 3 was supposed to
come out in the third week of September
in 2001 and then obviously because of
the 911 terrorist attacks they ended up
actually bringing it back in and
removing some imagery from the game
ended up coming out on the twenty-second
of October of that year so apparently
there were specific touches I think they
I'm not sure if it's been confirmed but
there's word that they took out some
sort of aspect of the twin towers that
were in Liberty City they also changed
stuff like the and cop cars were very
much like the NYPD ones and I think they
thought that I might have been tasteless
to keep them that similar so they change
the D cause on them oh yeah so that
stuff shows you how far back this goes
and and then of course probably the
latest one is grand theft auto heists at
GTA online heists which was supposed to
come out I think June of last year and
posed to launch with online but then
there right now it's not going to quite
be their launch and then who knows when
it could come and then all its gonna
come with PC yeah version but now I
think it's been delayed four times yeah
I poor Rob handlery who does some
fantastic Grand Theft Auto features on
gamespot like every couple of weeks like
all right and do my I sitting here and
then wait so easily god damnit like oh
it's been a delayed again poor guy and
so this is obviously something that
we've come to expect and even though
today you know a two months delay this
close to launch anyone else would be
like absolutely insane but we've almost
come to expect it from rockstar that's
what's so fascinating
to me is you think of a triple a game
you think of a GTA you think of these
huge games that have big marketing
campaigns scheduled and you know they
have so much momentum that they when
they set the release dates months and
months years sometimes in advance that
they're all trying to target here for
like maximum sales books success
whatever and then GTA like the history
you're just talking about like yeah
let's just pump in a week ah maybe like
next month we'll do it instead yeah you
know what this fall is not going to work
for us let's just make a next spring
like the length of the delays baffles me
because how much it varies but also I
mean I guess it's a de testament to
rockstar how good their games are that
like they still sell gangbusters and no
one and no one hasn't really caught up
with the story being like oh yeah that
delay really hurt rated Redemption yes
said the ones consistent thing I think
or rockstar games and maybe you'll agree
with this or not is that eat whenever
they come out they work like they're
generally polished or they don't have
that many bugs and these are like games
with so many different systems in them
like all the grand theft autos and red
dead redemption i'd say maybe i think
one of the versions of bully was a
little bit buggy and but like these
games work so do you think perhaps it's
something to do with just they hold
quality control to such a high standard
i want to raise an exception oh yeah
grand theft out of 4 i'm pc the first
few months when i was out was horribly
optimized yeah like garbage maybe
they're maybe they're just double
checking their work you know this time
around yeah like I but yeah you're right
like most of the times like for such a
complex world like these things work
pretty flawlessly so I bet you if
anything they're just yet double
checking to make sure that everything is
just like watertight totally solid and
not bunk well I guess we'll have another
couple of months to find that sadly
it'll be the end of marks before we get
to see perhaps the latest mod of pune
kins in GTA 5 or maybe that low friction
mod and i know folks are on the consoles
like who cares you can or we go to a
playstation 4 xbox 360 and everything
but come on we just want to see those
mods infer okay yeah what's wrong hey
any of you don't have the pc to run that
the mods you get the youtube exactly the
gold is so funny
which experienced on GTA 5 good see is
going to be pretty good yeah so that's
that that's it for a show guys thank you
very much coming out what are you guys
working on the moment on the side what's
what's going up well i'm doing is sort
of a bigger deep dive into playstation
now going to test out a bunch of
different network configurations working
on some stuff for the alienware alpha
fortunately sick for the holidays but I
mean we're stronger than ever which one
is that stronger than ever yeah whatever
it's that a little pc it's the little
one yeah it's not the big massive weird
healthier off if you hang yeah [ __ ]
ridiculous so yeah I'm gonna you guys
look for that next week we'll have a
review up was the anywhere else our
rigidness steam machine yes okay what's
happily quick steam machine update or I
read something that said that like the
steam machines are going to be like
officially launched some time in like
2015 but you're saying that everyone
else is pulling that like that title
away steam machines at this point are
well there's sort of two definitions or
it's any computer that say you can put
in your living room that ships with a
steam controller which valve is probably
going to show they will show off at GDC
and it may or may not boot into steam OS
which is a unix-based operating system
that does not use directx Microsoft's
thing for Windows that allows games look
all pretty and stuff uses OpenGL that
said wait three so many games are not
going to run on that sort of steam box
so I think that's a factor of the fact
that steam OS is progressing as such a
slow rate and the fact that people have
kind of just come to senses that a steam
machine is just a small pc yeah and it's
any pc that you can connect to your TV
I've been doing it for years millions of
other people been doing it for years
it's not some unique proposition yeah so
they're kind of dead but valves going to
show off their controller and that'll be
great for for couch gaming whether it's
going to do a steam machine or your PC
interesting Chris what are you working
on the one with ah getting prepped for
the fur axis mega panel at pax oh yeah
that was gonna be hosting after next the
two Coley designers have civ beyond
Earth as well as the man himself Sid
Meier great super stoked for that and
also getting a little cited to play any
evolved beta yes on xbox one starting in
like two days that's open beta
it is not but it's wider than its own
box one only okay and uh pre-ordering
gets you like it you unlock the third
monster in the third set of hunters
early I am not sure if it's open or
closed i think it might be open anyways
it's probably gonna be pretty easy to
get into it I think you can press beta
because there's been loads of alphas
there was the big alpha last August and
then like they've had like little spurts
of pc betas there in there so this is
their kind of big beta push and yep the
games out in like less than a month free
video game video game or you could just
play that resident evil HD remake REE
REE REE that's the reason why you think
of re yeah we remake it's probably been
a couple years since if a resident evil
right why aren't you playing it go
powers on it I've made it already week
next week said next Tuesday sorry jump
the place I think we're gonna play it
maybe maybe before then and we'll put it
up on the site maybe next weekend
talking like oh it's good game credit
watch because they can't sit some states
not breaking ball go if I say like oh
stop going on a good ya got your embargo
it's my burglar ways yeah and we the
sensitive information must be conveyed
to clients for our time hopefully Volvo
reduction to is officially coming on
they've delayed the pc version of GTA 5
so they can put a written read of them
to to demo in there what mmm god stop be
so [ __ ] way and you're sort of the
point yet this week on my ends right now
seven and you're going to do something
about that loading screen did you see
this the Namco patents on minigames
unloading screens is up at the end of
the year remember like Riley aamco yes
so his Konami had that as well no I got
it no Konami had a really yeah they have
way more did the highways are still you
could play a mini version of greediest
in there you could plague radius on
ridge racer as well no different
publishers but yeah but that was Galaga
oh I am I thinking of no one to get
galaxian okay either way well fine a
migraine more research on this week's
episode of point
but all that more on gamespot com over
the next couple days perhaps put a bit
more facts in a bit less waffling hey
careful Assad student right this way
thanks everyone in the back forever for
producing this week's show will be back
next week same bat-time 2 p.m. pacific
right here on gamespot com see you then
you
you